I think the 60s and 70s are kind of the
time when we experimented with Fame and
I think he was he ran the studio that
was almost a lab for being famous they
talked about a lot of people there's a
lot of actors a lot of artists a lot of
journalists who came out of there and he
created this culture of celebrity he
created a mystique and he was one of the
first ones to really do that and realize
that you could do it on a much larger
scale by branding people which is
something that's become commonplace
today but wasn't so common for people
back then it certainly was for cars and
light bulbs and everything else I think
he would say be authentic and have fun
with it because nobody had more fun with
it what you knew about Warhol was he was
in on the joke and I often tell my
celebrity she got to be in on the joke
when I worked with Monica Lewinsky we
went on Saturday Night Live she said why
would we do that and I said we have to
show that you get the joke and you know
early out of my career I represented LA
gear the the sneaker company and I got a
story for him in a major business
publication I got an advanced copy fax
to me that was the old days when we
faxed and I got this story and was a
horrible story the company eventually
had big financial problems is this
horrible story and I just started my
company less than a year before and I
said oh my god this horrible stories out
my business is going to go under I'm
going to be out on the streets eating
dog food and I called the friend of mine
and said it's over and he said Howard I
said yeah he said it's tennis shoes and
I've never forgotten that because ninety
nine percent of the time it's tennis
shoes okay it's tennis shoes it's not
life or death struggles that we're
talking about here and so you're allowed
to make a mistake that's the human
condition is to make mistakes and we
live in this great judeo-christian
culture that allows you to make mistakes
as long as you apologize up
contrite why did oj get convicted again
because he wasn't contrite okay it
wasn't so much about the mistake as the
lack of contrition on his part he stood
in court and said I didn't do anything
wrong if he had said I made a mistake I
acted out of arrogance I think the judge
and the jury would have been a little
more sympathetic towards